BUKOLA AYODELE: Today, we're
talking about security gaming
advancements in a new region.
I'm Bukola, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Cloud Armor and Google
Cloud's DDoS defense service
and Web Application Firewall--
WAF-- help customers protect
their websites and services.
We work constantly to stay
ahead of the evolving threat
landscape and are
excited to announce
a few updates, including the
preview of Cloud Armor Adaptive
Protection, a machine
learning-powered capability
to protect your applications
and services from layer 7 DDoS
attacks, four new preconfigured
WAF rules, and a reference
architecture.
Check out the blog
for more details.
Developed in collaboration
with Embark Studios,
Quilkin is a UDP
proxy tailor-made
for high-performance,
real-time multiplayer games.
With Quilkin, our aim is to
pull common functionality
and provide this
common functionality
in a composable and
configurable way, leading
to a reusable foundation that
allows game developers to spend
more time on building
the game-specific aspects
of building their multiplayer
communication protocols,
rather than the common aspects.
To support customers and public
sector in India and across
Asia-Pacific, we're excited to
announce that our new Google
Cloud region in Delhi
National Capital Region--
NCR-- is now open.
Designed to help both Indian
and global companies alike build
highly-available applications
for their customers,
the Delhi NCR region is
our second Google Cloud
region in India and our tenth
to open in Asia-Pacific.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.